皆さんはものの変化続くことができますでしょ
世の中は常に小さな変化大きな変化
変化に溢れています
何言ってんだこれマックシェイク準備します
まあ生育ってとてもバランと院員だと思うんですよ
ジュースみたいにかーって言ってるにもできないしてちまちまちまちま結構飲んじゃう
タイプだと思うんですけどのシェイクたが滑稽に見えていきたいなんでどう見やすいん
ですよこれで言論でも実はあんまりお腹ふくれないんじゃないかと思ってましてえっと
やっぱ濃霧と減るじゃないですか
シェイクってこれ見てもらったわかるんですけど減ってるかどうかってなかったがもう
曲静
ないんですよこの2つと曇ってるからだからきっとそのプレイヤーは飲んでも飲んでも
どれぐらい今減っているのかなっていうの中大体の坊さんにしか測れないんでいまいち
残りの容量が掴みづらい方からそれを利用した実験をしてみようと思います
名付けシェイクの中身を張れずにこそで増やし続けたら無限飲み続けるんじゃないか鉄
うん間違いないと思いますちょっとわからない取り組みため減っているかを
が今から仕掛けるんですけども仕掛けた人がぽっち宇宙の無抵抗
図5本でちょっとずつ減っていくわけじゃないですかねちょっと減った時にどこかに
移動させながら9引かせる
どこかに持って散らしてそちらしている間に僕がコストリーたくさんシェイクを買って
きたのでこのターゲットの成果の中にちょっとずつチェックをシェイクじゃないんで
ちょっとずつ性小葉
なより突き出していくことによって量が増えていることに気付かないけどチューチュー
チューチュー吸い続けて a じぇに mc 部分に続いてかもしれない
ラベルでと人間の基準的にシーク ml 大きさが重さっていうのはなかなか話し
づらいので多少減っぱところでそんなに巻かないと思うんですよの触った重量的な
わかりにく様らしい黙示的な判断をつかない
これで多少のんだシェイク羽化したところでもう気付かないんじゃないかで確率は
かなり高い泊まれるんですよ
8予備で多少無茶をしてでも成功を飲んでいるターゲットなんとこう気を紛らわして
その隙に僕がチークをどんどん付出して増えていることを張れてるなぁ本伸びるのか
設計したいと思います
ではいかんよ
[音楽]
ん
yeah
ガイアーゲン所
まずシェイクの m のストロベリーでいい
ヒムいい
ありません
goo
roo ドキンの2つ村瀬何かコンビみたいなパワー
ああああああ
ん
はい
はいえー
[音楽]
バッハ
ラーメンと見ちゃったん
このファー対する思いとは
これここはや開封になります
4日
悪いん
[音楽]
ええええええ
えっなんかアプリさ寿命
うーん味が分かります
分
ん
あった
だったと2回あるんです
20建つ当館です算術同月である方なん
に帰ります
じゃあにも続いたなるかん
不在票あるし見ていてねうん
暗算あるかもしれない気がします
なんかだんだんという
シェイプをどうぞ
プリズム方が俺が
[音楽]
ん
されています
うん
昔だったら
ヘッドスパしたいなぁ
ちょっとって
をも一番しているああ
あれば45的にはいらしいよ
[音楽]
ん
goo ん
[音楽]
ん
はい
バッハ
持っています
髪染めてう
のれますでも
[音楽]
wh
あっているん
ええええええ
enare 5
あまり書けません
そういうことだったけど者子さんをがってる
感じだった
ren
ああああああ
[音楽]
グループ e
me
どれがいいあんっああ
goo
の
[音楽]
ん基本5割と月で早送りへさぁ
2分を切った
ん
[音楽]
でますを目指す
mon ん
me
入ってが漏れている
母
あった
心を持ってるからー
思うんですっ
ね
[音楽]
つ考えています
me
こっちでなんかの sd つけていっ
ん
def
[音楽]
うん
一通り
2輪では
[音楽]
2分
うん
ふっ
風雲
ん
うん
シェイクべちゃべちゃじゃんっ
[音楽]
あっはい
ん
[音楽]
だって今日は何の資格だなぁ
続けた絶対おかしいも絶対何か仕掛けたよ俺は今日は引く考えす
[音楽]
あ
4日
ん
おっん
ウェーハッハッハ
[音楽]
me
良い子いてこんな方にもなるん
ねっ逆にあるんですか山
なんかでのん
スプラトゥーンようにとってますねそうだねー
me
バッハ
[音楽]
これらいい
car
uh
うううう
me
あっはぁ
あなたマックシーク m 何本飲んだか分かってますか
いやファーやそんなのんですよこれでもあなたが音何分そうだねー
本当に出そうだねあの席外すために
ちまって御中主突き出してあなたは両方のマックシェイクを飲んだ
0水の結果的に言うとシェイクの中身をバルディリスで変えても生まれません